les supporteurs de versailles sont
repartis du stade de porchefontaine
combler ce dimanche 10 octobre leurs
protégés ont largement dominé leurs
voisins de l'entente maisons laffitte ce
en gelant les poids si le derby noah a
été remportée sur le score de 35 à 12
aujourd'hui tout le monde a travaillé
ensemble pour l'équipe et ça fait
plaisir on a mieux 50 60 minutes à
débrider le match mais aujourd'hui les
ingrédients sont là y est ça fait
plaisir à gagner je suis très content
nous avons je pense qu'avec typhaine le
manager on est très content de la
victoire est là le comportement des
joueurs cet après midi
on avait vraiment envie d'avoir un match
référence un petit peu je montre un
petit peu l'état d'esprit du groupe et
on a pu voir aujourd'hui
contrat mais l'egypte est vrai avec
cette victoire face à un concurrent
direct pour le haut du classement les
versailles et grimpe sur le podium de la
poule une de fédérale 3 avec un match en
moins ils reviennent à un point de leur
adversaire du jour les objectifs
entre nous déjà rester humble le
week-end par week end et qui s'est
accroché les phases finales est monté
dans la division supérieure pour
continuer à rêver plus grands les
versets y affronteront et vous à
l'extérieur le 31 octobre prochain
[Applaudissements]